yes please you know police baby not the
police you got 120 for me
i'm 20. i'll give you a 100. that's what
i have right now all right man let's do
this that's perfect let's go okay
the majority of the tricks are mexican
this is cali you know
and
you want nothing to do with the black
dudes the young ones nothing to do with
the black dudes just leave me alone
because i know y'all [__] and i
don't want to hear it i really don't
it just sounds like
blibberish blubberish to me
blubberish and rhyming [__] you got no
time for that nonsense i don't it
irritates me i'll be like [__] you you
suck you have to like really see because
[__] makes the world go round
[__] kill for [__]
[__] will do anything
you know
you [__] their wife it's over with
you know their girlfriend
[__] take that [__] really seriously
so
you know i'm like [__] there's a whole
[__] business
surrounded by the fact
of you know how crazy men go for [__]
you